hey everyone this is keith now from
simply learn
welcome to this video on email marketing
full course
in this full course we will learn all
about one of the most trendy
technologies today
and that is digital marketing
we'll begin this full course video with
what email marketing is
and how to set up email marketing the
benefits of email marketing
and a b testing after this we will look
into the different types of email
campaigns
and how to engage new users with your
emails
along with a hands-on demo using the
mailchimp tool we will then conclude
this video
by discussing the essential interview
questions and answers to help
every individual crack an interview by
the end of this video
i can assure you that all your email
marketing career related
queries would have been answered for
this training with me
i have our experienced email marketing
specialist
rob together we will take you through
the various topics of email marketing
so let's start with an exciting video on
email marketing
before we begin make sure to subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
icon
never miss an update from simply learn
welcome everyone this is rob sanders
with simply learn
and welcome today we're going to talk
about email marketing tutorial
so buckle up and let's get started
with email marketing tutorial and so
let's start out asking the question
why email marketing so linda
is the owner of an e-commerce company
and
basically she isn't able to take her
leads leads she's collecting per day
per month and convert them into
customers okay so customers sign up but
they don't buy her product
so she's left scratching her head
wondering what to do
so how's she gonna solve the problem of
converting
the lead she gets into paying customers
well look no further than email market
so you can boost your sales funnel
with the help of email marketing so
email marketing
leads to email campaigns that lead to
website visits that can lead to product
purchasing
email markings also and a
it's a very good way to generate a high
return on
investment so linda thinks this is too
good to be true
you're telling me is a very efficient
way to generate
a return on my investment
how expensive is email marketing well
email marketing is neither expensive
or time consuming that's the beauty of
email marketing
and so linda is now very
interested we've piqued her interest she
wants
us to explain email marketing to her
in detail and that's exactly what we're
going to do
we're going to talk about email
marketing in detail so
for everyone out there listening what's
in it for you
why are you going to invest your time
and listening to
simply learn and me talk about email
marketing because
we're going to talk about everything
there is about email marketing
in today's webinar so what is it for
those that aren't really familiar
with the intricacies of email marketing
we're going to talk about how to set up
email marketing
we're going to discuss all the benefits
of email marketing
we're going to get into a b testing
we're going to get into the automation
of emails the
types of emails how to engage new users
and we're going to give you a demo
so there's a lot going on in this
webinar like i said buckle up and let's
get started
and talk about what is email marketing
so as i mentioned to linda it's an
efficient way to convert leads into
sales
why because we can send personalized
emails to a specific audience a targeted
audience
if somebody's interested in our product
we can reach out to them via email
it can also be used to remarket
pre-qualified leads
so anybody who's pre-qualified we can go
ahead
and communicate with them as well so
email marketing is a very
effective at different stages in the
funnel okay so when i say funnel
customer life cycle so we have awareness
consideration
purchase retention and advocacy okay so
let's talk about each one of these parts
of the
funnel or customer life cycle if you
will so let's start with awareness at
the very top
so email marketing allows customers to
recognize
their problems after which you can
educate them on how your brand can solve
them okay
just like any other marketing channel
somebody's looking for something
in need of something and we can come to
the rescue in this case we're going to
come to the rescue
with email and we can go ahead and
educate them
on what their need is and how we can
collaborate with them
help them educate them solve their
problems with our product okay
so that's what email is going to do
we're going to communicate with them via
email
and we're going to bring awareness to
the problem by solving the problem
that's what email is good for
okay good for generating awareness for
our brand
for example we can share a newsletter
with our customers
so we're running a cosmetics company
we can basically educate them on the
five important skin care products that
everyone should have
okay so we can get them to click on the
call to action to learn more
so if somebody's having some skin care
issues
or not sure what products to buy you
know an email can cover that okay the
next
step in the customer life cycle is
consideration so
customers focused on searching for
relevant products and
compares the products with similar ones
okay so they're definitely
looking they're a little further in the
process they're educated they know what
they're looking for
so we can really hit them with the right
email we can send a relevant email to
promote
our product okay discover that perfect
moisturizer for your skin
perfect skin moisturizer smooths
hydrates and contains spf 20 so we got
the perfect
product for that person who's further
along the funnel
and really is ready to purchase that
product so we can hit
that person up with the perfect
messaging talk about purchase
the next step in the life cycle well
purchase well with purchase we can send
an email that encourages that customer
purchase our product by offering them
something
okay by giving an offer for example we
can give a discount
discounts always tend to work so that
moisturizer that that
particular customer was considering
buying
well they can move from consideration to
purchasing because
we're going to offer them a discount
they can't refuse okay so
you know it could beat for a specific
date okay
it could be you know something that's
going to get them excited to buy the
product 20
off of moisturizers pretty good deal
and especially if that percentage off is
better than the other
products they were considering buying so
getting somebody that
extra incentive to purchase the product
goes a long way via email
okay we want to take that next step in
the life cycle and nurture
our relationship with customers to
ensure they're
loyal okay they've already purchased how
do we get them
purchased again that's retention we want
to retain
our customers we want to get them back
to buy the same product
or similar products or completely
different products in our inventory
so what do we do we're going to send an
email we're going to send an
email to active customers okay we're
going to give
them an offer just for them exclusively
just for them in this example we're
gonna give them a combo pack a facial
kit at just
39 and get a sunscreen worth ten dollars
for free
so you can come up with all sorts of
different combinations
on offers key is the offer is
exclusively just for those
who you want to target and retain as
customers
because if you just get somebody to
purchase once it's not going to work
those people have already
taken the that step in the relationship
where
they trust your product they purchase
your product now you want to go ahead
and
treat that customer special by giving
them an exclusive offer
and then what we want to do is advocacy
last step
in that customer lifestyle we want to
convert that active customer
into brand advocates okay we want that
customer
to talk about our brand for us we want
them to promote it and talk about it
with your friends
so for example we want to send an email
to those customers to promote our
products
okay so for example we could say hey the
sales of our products for this
particular day or for this month
is going to go to our favorite
non-profit could be educating poor
children
or cleaning up plastic in the ocean or
saving animals we want to be able to get
them to speak on our behalf and say look
guys this is a really good company you
know they're offering me products
exclusively
they've offered me discounts in the past
they have good products they have a lot
of different products
and on top of all that they help they
help the environment they help
the needy okay they care and so
we can go ahead and provide a call to
action
for these customers that are loyal to
our brand
and have them share the email with their
friends to spread the word
on you know what we're trying to
accomplish for our non-profit or
if anything just get them to promote it
maybe give them a discount
for every friend that they get to buy
our product
okay it doesn't have to necessarily be
you know just sharing with friends it
can be
that extra incentive of giving them a
discount if they do share with friends
and their friends buy
okay so this is the customer life cycle
and examples of different emails that
you can use at every step
along the way in the life cycle so let's
talk about
email marketing set up so email
marketing set up we have a series of
steps that we need to go through
in order to get our email set up
to go ahead and send out to our target
audience and that first step
is we want to identify that target
audience and create
segments so if you've taken some of my
and listened to some of my webinars in
the past
about google analytics about google ads
we talk about segmenting so it's about
targeting a specific audience that's
what segmenting is
taking a piece of the whole so we don't
want to email all users
on our list all customers maybe we want
to target a specific
segment okay so we want to be able to
identify that segment who is that
segment is it somebody who
or a group of people or you know a
partial list
of our customers who purchase a specific
product
i would say so versus say our entire
list of customers because our entire
list of customers can purchase
a number of different products and so by
targeting a specific
segment of our audience or our customer
base
we can hone in on the message so if they
all have something in common like they
all bought that moisturizer
then we can go ahead and be specific
with our messaging
then we want to create campaigns and set
an appropriate
call to action okay so what is it that
we want to say to these
these people this segment of users then
once you create that campaign and and
set up the messaging and call to action
we want to test the email before we
actually click send this is a very
important step
test that email before we send
and then when we send the campaigns
immediately or we can
schedule a time so my advice here is
always schedule a time you want to be
able to figure out
the best time to send that email
and then once the email is sent whenever
that is you want to be able to analyze
performance
and there are some key metrics that you
want to hone
in on when we talk about email marketing
and some of those are
open rates click through rates okay
response rate okay so
we want to be able to hone in on certain
key
metrics when it comes to emails so
here's what we need to do
create our list add contacts to our list
create our campaign
okay we want to select the list choose a
format
modify the template and then send the
email campaign so
these are some basic checklists that you
want to do so let me give you an example
and go to mailchimp so if i'm in
mailchimp
basically i'm going to create a campaign
okay
so it's an email that i'm going to work
with
and you can see with mailchimp i have
some some examples here regular
automated plain text or a b
test i want to do a regular email and
i'm just going to call it test
and i'm going to click begin okay so
we want to add our recipients who are we
going to add so we're going to choose
our audience okay so
we're just going to choose a sample test
for now okay
we can personalize the two fields if we
want
okay so what do we want to do we want to
call people by their first name their
last name the first and last name where
we can customize it just go with first
name to keep it a little bit personal
okay then we have the subject line here
so it's all about
messaging right so whoever we're
targeting
we want to be able to add a message so
we're just going to say and and subject
line is very key here so
you want to have a subject line that's
really going to resonate with your
audience so whoever that
segment audience is we want to make sure
that the subject line is going to
resonate with
with them so that they can open up that
email okay so
uh we'll just say having a good day we
can make it better
just as an example something that's
gonna be attention-grabbing if you will
okay you can always tweak the subject
line in fact
my advice is always do a b testing on
the subject line so you can do
two different subject lines with one
email to figure out
which one has better open rates and then
with mailchimp we can go ahead and
design the content
of our email so we're going to click
design email okay we can
select a template we have some saved
templates already
okay or we can go with a theme so
mailchimp has a lot of good offers now
there's a lot of different
email platforms out there i particularly
like mailchimp because
of this very feature they have a lot of
good themes here
a lot of different layouts that you can
use okay so
you know we're gonna showcase that
product okay and that's the template
we're gonna use here so here we go
we're gonna showcase our product we're
gonna add that photo of our product here
and we're gonna go ahead and put some
nice messaging in here
with some nice call to action we can put
our logo up here for branding
again we can edit the content here so
based on that
segmented list in this example for
linda's company maybe she wants to
target those folks
who bought her moisturizer before her
face
moisturizer and she wants to retarget
them she wants to go ahead and say hey
you guys have bought my product before
check out this
new face moisturizer that we have to
offer so whatever the case
is you want to be able to plan that out
ahead of time you want to be able to
plan out who your audience is
you want to plan out your messaging and
you want to
go ahead and set up the messaging based
on that audience
so once you have the messaging in place
voila you're more or less
ready to go okay so once you get the
content all set up
you can schedule that campaign okay and
you can
also add a social post to your campaign
so we can share
that information on social so email
integrates
nicely with social media so again that's
that's pretty much
what you need to do here you need to
really think about
who it is you want to target choose
those recipients
okay customize it and make it personal
create a good subject line in fact
create two subject lines
and then align that content with that
audience
okay that's that's really the checklist
here so again we look at this checklist
creating our list who do we want to send
the email to so we added our contacts to
the list
we set up the campaign we selected the
list
we chose the format we modified it with
a good subject line
with some good messaging and then we're
going to schedule that email campaign
so that's the checklist to go off okay
so remember identify target audience and
create segments
then you create that campaign and in our
case we did set an appropriate call to
action
you know get shopping basically we want
people to shop our new moisturizer
key thing here is before we send it out
we want to test that email
once everything looks good we're going
to i would advise schedule it but you
can always send the email when you're
ready
i would schedule it at the appropriate
time and day okay so in this case you
don't want to send an email out on a
friday afternoon
okay when people are getting ready for
the weekend you certainly don't want to
send an email out over the weekend
because
you're not going to have many people
look and open it and you probably don't
want to send the email out on a monday
morning when most people are
getting into the office from a long
weekend and
catching up on emails so from my
experience
you know tuesday wednesday depending on
your time zone i would always say
you know late morning early afternoon
tends to be a good time but
that's why we have performance that's
why we can analyze performance we want
to be able to see what the open rates
are and the click-through rates are so
that we can make adjustments for future
emails so let's talk about
some of those metrics so when you do
send that email
you know we're going to look at that
open so open rate is the percentage of
the total number of recipients who open
an email so okay so if we basically
you know send it to x amount of people
minus those emails that have bounced so
let's just say
you know we sent it to 102 people
okay for simplicity's sake two of those
emails bounced
okay so that means that we've had a
hundred net
100 emails that received the email and
let's just say 75 open the email
okay we wrote such a good subject line
that
they opened it okay that's 75 that's a
75
open rate that's how you measure open
rate click through rate okay so if they
open it
we hope that they click on something and
so
for all of those emails that were
delivered okay in this case a hundred
how many actually did click on our call
to action so
let's just say 75 opened it
out of the 100 that's a 75 open rate but
of the hundred that actually were
delivered let's just say
we had 25 that actually clicked on the
call to action
and so that's 25 okay and so you want to
be able to measure not only who
opens it but who clicks on the call to
action so that's click-through rate for
email marketing
and then response rate so it's the
percentage of the total recipients
who clicked on a link of your email
campaign and actually completed the
action
so in our example we're trying to get
people to click on the shopping call to
action
and get them to purchase so we sent 100
emails
and of the 25 who actually clicked
we had 10 who actually took action and
purchase
so 10 divided by 100 is 10
so you have open rate click through rate
and response rate those are some
key metrics for email marketing okay the
first step is you got to get people to
open it that's where the subject line
is so important click their way that's
where the messaging and call to action
is so important we want to get people to
click on that call to action
and then the response rate we want them
to buy so those are our three key
metrics related to email marketing
so let's take a look at an example if we
go back to our email marketing platform
mailchimp in this example we're going to
take a look at
some reports so most email marketing
platforms
have reporting functionality built in
and so in this case
what we want to do is we want to be able
to take a look at the open rate
click-through rates
of the emails that have been sent out
previously so
here we could see our april email coupon
versus tools promo okay so we've had
basically you know opens and clicks so
14 open rate 1.4
click-through rate okay so the march
email that went out
did a little bit better 19 open two and
a half percent on the click-through rate
so here we could see how many people
actually
were sent how many open it and how many
clicks so this is a mailchimp makes it
very
easy for us to measure you know open and
click rates and then
we can measure by revenue as well based
on
the campaign so that's measuring the
response rate
so it's all built in so most email
marketing platforms
have open rate and click rate already
built
into the functionality so you can
measure those two
metrics against any email so let's talk
about the benefits
of email marketing so what are some of
the benefits
well we've already mentioned to linda
that it's cost effective
it's time saving real time marketing
less intrusive builds credibility
increases
visibility and brand awareness and it's
an easy way to track roi
these are all the benefits for email
marketing we're gonna go
talk about some of these now so
basically when we talk about
cost effective you know some email
marketing platforms
charge based on the number of users who
you send the email to time saving well
you saw how quick it took me
to set up that email campaign the key is
figuring out who you want to send it to
when we talk about real-time marketing
you know we're sending this
email out basically in real time
trying to meet our customers needs at
the right time
it's less intrusive because we can
customize the emails okay we can
as you saw i can put first name in there
to make it more
personal so when something's more
personal it's less intrusive especially
if it's a segment that already knows
your brand okay builds credibility hey
we gain
credibility when we offer exclusive
offers to repeat customers or you know
try and build advocacy
by working with nonprofits okay it
increases visibility and brand awareness
why because
you know we could send our email out to
a large group of people
and that's a good way to generate brand
awareness
and as you saw we can easily measure you
know not only open rates click rates but
roi so how many people from that email
went on and purchased so we can measure
that
it's very easy to measure email so let's
move into
a b testing so a b testing is
key to email marketing okay so in email
marketing
gaining high open rates and
click-through rates will result in more
website visitors and sales okay in
theory
that's what's supposed to happen we get
more opens we get more people to click
we get more people to click we're going
to get more people to purchase
okay but it's not as easy as it sounds
so how do we make that possible well
we're going to do that via
a b testing i've already mentioned it
when i set up my example
campaign in mailchimp i stressed and
stressed and stressed
that we need to have two subject lines
go out
per email okay so before i stress that
again
let me just reiterate what a b testing
is and a b testing is a method to
analyze
which of the two email campaign
strategies most effective
in terms of high open rates and click
rates okay so in this case an a b
testing you can send out two emails
you can send out two subject lines you
can send out two call to actions
you're just really what you're doing is
you're testing one
against the other that's what a b
testing is and so
in my example i talked about that
subject line so for better results a b
testing can be done with the subject
line can also be done with the email
content
so the subject line impacts the open
rate okay so i wrote a subject line i
don't even know how that subject line is
going to perform
but if i write a second subject line
then
i'll be able to basically give myself a
better chance of getting a better open
rate because i'm offering up
two different subject lines likewise for
email content
so the subject line and email content
are the most important elements
so we want to be able to test them if
they're interesting intriguing
attention grabbing then it's gonna in
the case of subject lines a result in
open rates
if the content itself is interesting
engaging
a good offer good call to action then
the click rates are going to be
increased so we want to be able to serve
up variations for
our audience so we want to consider an
example of an a b
test where linda has set up two
variations
of the email campaign as an example so
she's gonna send two different subject
lines to test
which one generates more open rates
because that's what
subject line a b testing is going to do
one of them is going to have a higher
open rate okay
so in our example here linda sends
version a
of the email to 50 of the recipients
with
the subject line three important
strategies to increase your open rate
well
version b which is sent to the other 50
percent
has the subject line three important
strategies to increase
your open rate so the only difference
here is
three and three the number three spelled
out well
because she sent out two different
subject lines she's going to now
be able to measure the success of that a
b test
okay and it just so happens version a
has a higher open rate
numbers always tend to work in subject
lines by the way
so linda sends version a of the email to
50
of the recipients okay eighty dollars
today but ninety dollars tomorrow and
version b to the remaining fifty percent
eighty dollars today
ninety dollars tomorrow and the only
really succinct difference here
is using the word but versus a comma and
she sent that email out
and that email went out and the date is
coming in and she's gonna measure the
success
of that a b test well version b has the
higher open rate you know we want to be
short
succinct and stay away from those
conjugations like but okay
it tends to have a negative connotation
so the shorter
more direct email our subject line 80
today 90 tomorrow not so passive
more direct and that tend to have the
higher open rate so you always want to
test those subject lines to generate
high open rates another example here
version a
again gets 50 with the subject line
uh-oh
your prescription is expiring version b
your prescription is expiring you folks
listen to this webinar right now i
wonder
which one you think will perform go
ahead and put your comments
right below this video i'm curious what
version of the subject line you would
open so
let's go ahead and measure the success
of the a b test okay so she sent the
email out
two different subject lines fifty
percent got one
subject line the other fifty percent got
the other subject line
and it just so happens version a uh-oh
your prescription is expiring there's a
little bit of a
you know personalization to that you
know for me your prescription is
expiring
seems to be a little bit more you know
command-ish
hey your prescription's expiring so we
expect you to purchase
where you have a little uh-oh in front
it's like hey
you know i think your prescription is
expiring maybe you should think about
renewing it okay i think that's how
that's interpreted at least that's how i
interpret it so i would probably go
ahead and click on that email with that
subject line so you could see
subtle differences in the subject lines
make a big difference in open rates so
in order to keep improving those open
rates you need to continue
and not continue should always do
subject line
testing always because one subject line
is always going to have a better open
write than the other
so always do a b testing when it comes
to subject lines
and email content for that matter okay
so
we're always going to do continuous a b
testing so
with continuous a b testing we can test
very
various elements of the email so you can
always test the sender's name the
subject line the copy the call to action
the design the imagery
there's a lot of different elements you
can test
with emails for example center's name
okay so you want to personalize it as
much as you can
okay you don't want to do a no reply
you want it to come from a human being
in this case sam
okay at least that's what i think let's
see what the
test states no surprise version a
has the higher open rate if you
customize these things and personalize
them
then it goes a long way sending an email
from a no reply is not
a good best practice let's talk about
the subject line again uh so we got
webinar
increase your email open rates webinar
increase your email open rates
so the webinar is dynamic on version a
okay so we're sending that out and
because it's dynamic
that's going to you know beat out the
static
webinar increase your email open rates a
lot more elements we can test here
so for example the email copy so learn
some easy ways to increase your email
open rates join us on may 10
2019 7 p.m for an interactive discussion
with our experts
well version b is more personalized it's
a same message
but we're actually addressing someone
specific in this case
rachel so we can measure the success of
the a b
test but it's no surprise that anything
that's customized
that comes from somebody a name you know
with a dynamic
email subject line is going to perform
better it's going to increase
open rates and it's going to increase
click rates so
we can also test that call to action the
difference here is
coloring save my seat yellow versus save
my c
blue again go ahead and play along here
if you're watching this go ahead and add
a comment and just see if you're right
you think it's blue or you think it's
yellow on the call to action
color does go a long way in email
marketing so let's measure the success
of this a b
test and it just so happens yellow is
going to perform better why does yellow
perform better than blue
well it's more positive plus it it kind
of resonates a little bit stronger
and easier okay it stands out a little
bit better
it's not as pastely and dull as this
shade of blue we're using
so you can see here we're testing every
bit of the elements of the email
anything from the from
to the subject line to the message to
the call to action
and so at the end of the day you know
you want to be able to
send out the best email that's going to
give you the best results
so we're going to send that out the
entirety of the email
and we could see version a looks a lot
better and why does version a look a lot
better in this example because look at
the font size
is a little bit bigger version b font
size smaller harder to read
that's another thing you can test larger
fonts tend to do a little bit better now
you don't want to go overboard and have
them
you know 48 points or 50 points and plus
you know 14 versus 12 goes a long way
we can continue testing we can test
imagery
you can see here we have a hand aligned
with the call to action
they just look different that's all
version a has
one type of hand version b has the other
type of hand
aligned with the call to action let's go
ahead and send out that test and see
what works well
version b works why the hand stands out
a little bit more clear it doesn't blend
in
with the call to action so you can see
we're testing different elements here
and we're always
improving and adding to what's working
so we started out with
a no reply versus somebody's name
then we move to a subject line then we
move to
personalization then we move to
you know call to action then we move to
an increased font
meaning the design and then we're adding
imagery so we're constantly
improving the email with each test
eventually you're going to get to a
point where
you know the email is going to be good
and you're going to just continue to
test
different options on it to continue to
increase
open rates click rates and response
rates
final output looks like this again that
personalized email
response from sam versus no reply
you know we got a nice dynamic subject
line
gotta personalize the email to rachel
with larger font
okay we got a nice call to action that
stands out
with a nice image to accompany that so
we've tested all these different
elements this is the best
combination based on everything we
tested so when we get that email to go
this is what it's going to look like in
the future but guess what we're not
going to stop
testing so we can continue to test those
subject lines continue to test the
messaging and continue to test the
email design continue to test different
call to actions
continue to test different images you're
never going to stop
testing with email marketing okay so
let's switch over
to how to optimize the subject line
subject line is
such a key component to email marketing
so
as we showed you in the last segment we
tested a subject line
and we used a number the number three
versus three spelled out
just so happens that numbers tend to do
a little bit better they're shorter
easier to read and they resonate better
so including number in your subject line
you can include an emoji in your subject
line your emails come a long way
emojis aren't just social media based
you can
use emojis in subject lines i'd highly
recommend it you know i just sat
on an email last month with the subject
line about
you know spring showers bring may
flowers and guess what emoji i had in
that subject line
a flower okay may sound cheesy but it
goes a long way
so according to experian subject lines
with emojis can increase
open rates by 45 percent people resonate
with emojis especially if they're
positive emojis
okay so we want to personalize those
subject lines for better
open rate okay when i say personalize
don't be so stale
remember that subject line we tested
uh-oh just putting
uh-oh in there made it sound like we
actually cared it was a little bit
personal it wasn't so personal you
weren't dressing a specific
person but one little word goes a long
way in a subject line because when
people get emails and they read emails
and a lot of people are inundated with
emails
the subject line is what they're reading
first and just by
personalizing it adding a number adding
an
emoji
just making it positive and easy to read
they're likely to open an email
so personalized email messages can
improve
click through rate and open rates as
well so you want to personalize your
email as much as you can
whether that be from the from field to
putting that person's name
in the salutation so personalized
subject lines have been found to
increase
open rates by up to 50 percent so don't
come across
as spammy come across as you know who
your audience is and you're talking to
them and then
you want to prefer title case subject
lines
so title case subject lines for example
when i say
title case game of thrones is my
favorite show
every initial letter in that title
is capitalized okay you can go with the
sentence case game of thrones is my
favorite show
it doesn't stand out as much of course
if you go with lower case
it definitely doesn't stand out it looks
illiterate and
somebody's probably not going to open it
so you always go with that title case
the every
initial letter gets capitalized so how
to optimize that subject line well
watch the length of your subject line
you want to be
conscious of character counts so 17 to
24
characters you want to keep it short
succinct
and to the point but personalized with
an emoji
with initial caps on each word to make
it stand out
but you have to do that within 17 17 and
24 characters
so according to campaign monitor the
ideal length of a subject line
is up to 24 characters and they're more
likely to boost those email rates
okay so keep it short make it impactful
make it personalized like i mentioned
before
if you get too long then it may get cut
off and it may not
have the same impact as something
shorter so that's why
we always recommend keeping it up to
about 24 characters okay if you go over
by a couple characters
not the end of the world but try and
stay within that range
develop a sense of urgency okay so when
we say sense of urgency
we mean sense of urgency meaning if that
coupon is going to expire
you know you want to let people know
it's going to expire that day or the
next day or within a few days
okay so you can use things like hurry up
or limit
offer or limited stock or offer expires
on
okay so add a bit of sense of urgency i
mean
sky's not falling here but if that
coupon's expiring
at the end of the week you probably want
to mention something
to the effect of hey offers expiring or
hurry up
so let's talk about optimizing your
email content so we focused a lot on
subject lines let's talk about the email
content itself
so some ways to optimize email content
are we want to send the content that is
relevant to
customer expectations so content needs
to match that expectation
we want to use bullet points to make the
content readable
we want to follow logical structure we
want to use compelling imagery
and prefer design emails with responsive
designs and what we mean by responsive
design
is hey most people are going to be
checking that email
on their mobile phone okay so make sure
when you design the email
it's also going to be good not just on
desktop
but on tablet and mobile as well and
then of course
just goes without saying but avoid
grammatical mistakes
go ahead and spell checked it and that's
why we put an emphasis on testing your
email before you actually send
it and when you actually send an email
test email
don't send it to yourself send it to
colleagues
you know send it to another group a
fresh set of eyes
a fresh set of eyes like it's going to
be able to pick out
that misspelled word that you overlooked
so
i can't stress the sending of the test
email because
it's going to be able to you know in a
way
ensure that you're doing everything on
this list in addition to grammatical
mistakes
you know the person who's receiving your
test email your colleague at work
may be looking at that email on their
mobile phone and if it doesn't look good
to them
they're gonna let you know some other
ways to optimize email content
personalization so we did that on the a
b testing you always want to personalize
it
question is hey do i use first name do i
use first and last name
well guess what you can test that but
you want to personalize it okay you want
to choose the right fonts and colors for
your email
so when we were going through some
examples on testing
you know i always tend to go a little
bit larger on the font
but you can play around with it i don't
think you should probably
use white lettering on a black
background that just
is not very good or best practice
but go ahead and try it if you want okay
you can always play around
and test these but you want to choose
something that's really going to
resonate
with the recipient of the email okay you
want to build a rapport with customers
by
sharing insights they value for example
the beginning of this webinar we talked
about advocacy we talked about
you know sharing with them some of the
non-profits that
we work with as a company okay if we
have a
you know cosmetics company and we have
different products like moisturizers
and facial creams we may want to state
that hey we don't use
any animals in the testing of these
products you know we're pro
animal we're not you know we're not
going to use animals in the testing of
our products
and that probably resonates with a lot
of your customers so you want to
go ahead and build a rapport with those
customers by sharing those insights
okay and use recipient names and you
always want to
personalize it then add a clear call to
action at the end you always want to
have that call to action
regardless of what the email is hey it
could be just a simple
read more or hey donate it doesn't have
to
always be so hardcore in terms of hey
purchase our product
that could be a turn off especially if
you're sending emails out once a week to
your customer base they're constantly
hammering them
with buy now buy now by now they're
going to get turned off so you want to
mix
up the call to actions and that goes
back to the very first step
and what kind of email are you going to
send out and who are you going to send
it to so you have to align those two
with somebody who doesn't even know who
your brand is
you're not going to put a call to action
of buy now
you're probably going to say hey check
us out we have some cool
stuff for you okay let's talk about
automating emails email automation
so triggered emails are sent to
customers
based on an event date or user behavior
okay so when we say
an event could be a special occasion
like mother's day
okay could be a date like a birthday or
anniversary or specific day of the week
could also be based on user behavior you
know a good example of user behavior are
those who abandon the car
you can trigger an email in fact
mailchimp has remarketing
functionality so with mailchimp hey if
somebody abandons our car
we can have an email triggered and we
can send an email
a nice email that says hey we noticed
you didn't finish
purchasing our product and i'm not sure
what happened but hey here's another 10
off or you can always just make product
recommendations as well but
you want to react to user behavior and
use the emails to your advantage for
that
so you want to take be cognizant of
different occasions
you want to be cognizant of special
events holidays
etc and user behavior so these types of
emails can be automated because
you know when they might happen or that
they are probably going to happen so
auto responder emails are sent at
frequent intervals based on the behavior
of subscribers
so for example if somebody purchases
something then you're gonna get an email
that probably says hey thank you for
your purchase another email that says
hey your product's on its way
and then another email that says hey
your package your product has been
delivered
so that's an example of an automated
email that goes out if somebody
purchases your product you probably want
to thank them for that
then you probably want to let them know
that hey it's on its way
here you could track it and then again
you want to confirm that it's been
delivered but thank them again
so that's an example of an automated
email that goes out
okay let's talk about types of email
campaigns
so we have different types of email
campaigns
and the first is a newsletter so with
email newsletters subscribers are
connected and informed about product
updates
so it doesn't necessarily have to be a
product they buy
it could be a product they subscribe to
like software
okay you always want to be able to send
out that newsletter to let them know
what's going on
with your product are there upcoming
product updates ahead
is there one that just happened is there
a webinar that discusses
the new product update so that's what
the newsletter is going to do inform
the end user about the update so how to
optimize
okay so you stack your email content
create a compelling header
share different variety of useful
content like videos articles etc with
those recipients
and then follow a consistent schedule so
that's how you handle a newsletter you
should always create a compelling header
but if you're going to send a newsletter
make sure you support it with some good
information like a video that they can
go watch or an article that
will follow up on what you put in the
email or
promoting that webinar that's going to
talk about that product update
so example here is a newsletter that
gets sent
out and here you can see it talks about
business process
it's got some nice imagery in there okay
call to action
it's got a little bit of everything in
this email template okay
and that's when we talk about stack your
email content that's what you talk about
stacking
you can see at the top it's got work
with the industry best
subscribe now okay they validate that
with 25 years of top-notch service
then they talk about hiring the best
talent and you got the next bit of
content below that so that's stacked
email content
okay that's going to be supported by
compelling header and then
they're going to share a variety of
different content in there
like there could be clicks in there to
video videos and articles
moving on from newsletters to
promotional emails so we want to be able
to drive revenue by
sending special offers through
promotional email
okay so how do we optimize a promotional
email well we want to personalize
the campaign okay promotional we want to
definitely personalize it
include time sensitive offers we want to
get people to react
okay so that means you know adding a
sense of urgency in the title
and the subject line okay you can send
offer emails on holidays if it's
mother's day
hey send it a couple days before or even
send it on
if it's personalized then you can say
hey so and so
we know you're a mother here take 20 off
i mean that kind of personalized email
with an offer goes a long way
here you an example from toms limited
time
extra 20 off all styles they include the
code in there
okay again you can see the the
sensitivity
and the sense of urgency with the
limited time
another email campaign type and
personally one of my favorites is
abandoned cart
so abandoned card emails i like working
with
the bandit card emails because you know
we want people to purchase
and as much as you try on your email
marketing campaign to drive traffic to
the website
and as hard as the website works to get
people to convert
through the shopping cart it's never
gonna be a hundred percent
and so abandon cart emails give us that
extra incentive to get that person back
to the shopping cart to purchase
okay so these emails are shared with
customers who have added product to
their cart
but didn't finish through the checkout
process in other words they didn't
purchase the product so it's an
effective way of sales recovery it gives
us another opportunity to reach out to
that person
who just is almost there but not quite
ready to finish the purchase so what are
we going to do we're going to send out
an email for those that abandon their
car and we're going to use a simple
abandoned cart email template okay you
want to be simple here
you don't want to get complicated we're
trying to make this easy for them to
finish
purchasing the products and we want to
definitely personalize it
okay we want to send a series of email
reminders
okay in your email reminder add a
product image
so as customized as it can be it could
be
even the product image of what they've
abandoned
and that's the best practice so if it's
that facial moisturizer that linda's
trying to promote
and she can't quite get enough people to
finish
purchasing the product they're they're
banning the cart
well she can certainly send out the
abandoned cart email okay
so for example you want to personalize
it
hey you forgot to complete your order
you left something in your car
can we help email too hi there so and so
items in your shopping cart are selling
out quickly it's a gentle reminder
okay so come across a little bit
different here
okay email three hey so-and-so twenty
percent off on your car
valid until so-and-so offer on your
favorite product
so the first email that went out in the
series of emails
hey you forgot something hey is there
anything we can do to help you
complete the product purchase email two
is just that gentle reminder hey you're
selling out quickly
you might want to purchase that product
and email three is to really help them
along by saying hey
here's twenty percent off valid until so
and so so
just a small series of emails that go
out
try and get somebody back into the
shopping cart
okay let's talk about re-engagement
campaign so in a re-engagement campaign
it's a series of emails sent to
inactive email subscribers so what it
does is it boosts engagement and helps
to maintain a high
inbox placement ratio inbox
placement ratio so we want to be able to
make sure that we're getting people
back on our subscriber list so how are
we going to optimize for something like
this
this is now these are difficult type of
email campaigns we're trying to
re-engage with people who are inactive
so we want gamification to re-engage
subscribers or
we want to prefer subject lines like hey
we've been missing you
or did we do something wrong okay we can
run a poll or
competition to re-engage with those
subscribers so for example
hey we'd hate to miss your birthday go
ahead and update your account this is a
starbucks
email so we'd hate to miss your birthday
so
it's that you know message of missing
you you can always
soften or sweeten the deal with an offer
as well
so that brings us to how to engage with
new subscribers
so we just talked about re-engaging with
inactive
we want to talk about engaging with new
subscribers so how to engage with new
subscribers well
thank your subscribers for joining okay
create
clear and compelling subject lines that
is a must
regardless of what type of email you
send out you
always want to send out that compelling
subject line
okay we noticed the good examples within
17 to 24 characters know the
ideal time to message okay again
sending it on the weekends not going to
work okay sending it out during the
weekday
you know in the morning mid morning you
know
sometimes in the afternoon works really
depends on who your audience is
but weekends probably aren't going to
work okay avoid the no reply center name
again
personalize it you're either sam or rob
or so and so sally
you know let them know that the emails
come from a real person
okay because if it doesn't come from a
person most people aren't going to
respond
okay we want to let our subscribers know
the privacy policy
so we want to let them know that we
abide by
a privacy policy okay that's you know
getting you know straight with people
who are new they don't know your brand
they don't know your privacy policy
they don't want to get spammed in other
words so putting that out there
makes you more transparent and
trustworthy okay and again
personalization always personalize if
it's new
if it's inactive repeat customers loyal
customers lifetime customers
you should always personalize and you
should always be courteous
and always thank them and then prefer
attractive email designs okay
work with something that's going to be
eye catchy and then
most important most important is include
an unsubscribe link i can't tell you
how annoying it is to get an email
and not have the unsubscribe link there
that makes me
want to unsubscribe even if it was a
good email
i still look for that because maybe
they're good company but they're
spamming me they're sending me too many
emails so maybe i want to unsubscribe or
change my subscription
so you always want to include that
unsubscribed link in fact in the united
states it's actually
law so there is regulation about that
around that so you need to include an
unsubscribe link it's just common
courtesy
if anything so it bodes well okay of
course you don't want people to
unsubscribe
but you don't want them to get annoyed
either okay let's talk about
email marketing tools so we talked about
mailchimp
so there are plenty of email marketing
platforms out there
i use mailchimp i've used a few in the
past
like marketo i've used zoho vertical
response
so there are a lot of different tools
out there here some of them
again mailchimp marketo marketo is a
marketing automation tool or system
and marketo is good for sending those
automated emails
hubspot convertkit send in blue
aweber i mean these are just some of the
many
that are out there okay so let's show a
demo again of
an email marketing campaign so let's
show an example
of a newsletter that one of my clients
it sent out and so this is paul eckman
group paul ekman dr ekman
inspired the tv show lie to me so well
known
in the industry of micro expressions
he's the aforementioned
expert in micro expressions and he sends
out email marketing campaigns
and he sends out a monthly newsletter so
this is a
a newsletter was sent out in november
2018
and if we look at it you can see here
okay it's stacked content
nice imagery okay respectful
disagreements how to deal with
disagreements
this holiday season so really relevant
personalized because and timely because
it was set in november
during the holiday season so got some
nice imagery there
okay we got content in here and then
right below that on the stack content
what do we have
final hour 24 hours 25
off so that sense of urgency built in
to the email then here you go you have
some other content in there based on
the face of contempt okay just an
example of a micro expression
and then right below that what do we see
we see a call to action
learn how to use microexpressions to
your advantage
so call to action here then we have some
more
information here with the learn more so
a newsletter that went out
basically a blog post built into the
email with some nice content
reminding folks hey they have 24 hours
got some other
useful information in the email so
this email went out very timely 98 000
okay see subject line here controversy
respectful disagreements and
thanksgiving
okay could the subject line be a little
bit shorter yes
possibly but if we look at the open rate
15
16 open rate okay industry average
in education and training is 18 okay so
they're close to the industry average
on the click rate you know 1.6 percent
on the click rate
industry average 2.1 so we can see
what the top links were clicked okay so
they have a lot of links and and
mailchimp will help you measure what
links were clicked the most
who subscribed what subscriber with the
most opens
we can see opens by country but that's
an example of a newsletter
for this particular company okay stacked
content
okay sense of urgency okay you can see
the subject line
timely newsletter so this is a
a good i think a good example of an
email
for the time of year okay so let's go
over the checklist again
for email marketing so good reminders on
the checklist this is a checklist
you want to make sure all boxes are
checked
you want to create interesting subject
lines as they boost your open rates
direct correlation with open rates is
subject line okay you want to keep your
content relevant and consistent with
your brand
you want to check the sender name okay
so you want to make sure
not only is it personalized but the name
aligns with the email address okay you
should always personalize
always personalize the subject line and
the email copy text
meaning you know don't just say hello
say hello
to sally pete rob michael
etc always include an unsubscribe
link in emails okay give people the
option to unsubscribe okay
you can always re-engage them another
way or later on
but you don't want to irk any one of
your potential customers
use a b testing we talked about a b
testing the webinar
there's lots of different elements we
can test from subject line to content
to font to call to action to imagery
to subject line etc there's no shortage
of elements in an email you can test
you want to use welcome emails to build
good customer relationships so when
somebody signs up for a newsletter
send out a welcome news email to them
hey welcome
thank you for signing up you should
always
segment your list based on user behavior
so
you have a group of people who purchase
product a
customize your email for product a but
you know you can mention
product b and c in there but know who
your audience is
so you can talk to your audience and you
can always ask your subscribers to
update their preferences as well
because you want to make sure you're
sending out emails to the right
person right address okay this is a
short checklist
now we can expand upon this but these
are some of the most
of the key items when it comes to email
marketing
some other items on the checklist
include features such as countdown
timers and live polls
okay make it interactive okay choose the
right email frequency
don't be sending emails three or four
times a week
you know once a week is probably as much
as you want to go
depending on what it is if somebody
purchases something
then you probably want to send an email
thanking them for the purchase
another one letting you know the product
has been shipped and another
one with thank you the product has been
received
reward those subscribers send out
exclusive offers
okay make sure your emails are optimized
for mobile
that means send out test emails and
check it on
different devices create a schedule okay
you can automate these emails so create
a schedule
that makes the most sense have a footer
and
header in the email and in that footer
and header is going to be some
information
okay just like i showed you with the
micro expressions
there was a footer and header avoid spam
filters
okay how do you avoid spam filters well
apply best practices
and don't have spammy subject lines have
an
actual name associated with the reply to
email
and and split up your list as well when
you send out one email
to 150 000 people it could probably get
caught up
in some spam so segment out your
audiences
keep your audience list short so that
your messaging can be
specific to the audience that's gonna
help avoid spam
and then of course you always want to
measure and analyze results
so remember a lot of these email
marketing platforms
have the results built in especially
open rates
and click rates some key takeaways from
today's webinar we talked about what is
email marketing
so email marketing really is an
effective way
to really give get a good message out to
a target audience
plenty of benefits doesn't cost a lot of
money to do email marketing
okay you can do it in real time it
doesn't take a lot of time
okay and you can get some roi out of it
we also talked about a b testing that's
a very
key component to email marketing if
you're gonna do email marketing
at the very least test those subject
lines but there's so many different
elements you can test
okay we talked about the types of
different email campaigns
from newsletter to promotional
abandonment cart to re-engagement
re-engaging those inactive users
so each type of email campaign is going
to contain a different way to talk to
them
okay how to engage with new users okay
so we went
over a best practices list for engaging
with new users
some of which means and personalizing
okay you always use an attractive email
you want to come across
the very first time with the right way
always always always create a clear and
compelling subject line
if it's a new or returning recipient you
always
want a clear and compelling subject line
and then there's plenty of email
marketing tools
you know i showed you mailchimp
mailchimp has some really good features
in it if i go back to mailchimp again
just to drive home the point
okay so you you can look at specific
look at really specific data per email
it has reporting built in
it has all these nice little templates
built in so you can create a template
okay you can leverage a template and
there's lots of templates you can use
they even have a content studio so it
has a
lot of features built into the platform
this is just mailchimp i mean
marketo and hubspot and aweber and all
these other platforms
do very similar things you just have to
pick the one that works for you
the best today we're going to talk about
mailchimp so we're going to go through
the features and benefits of using
mailchimp as your email content platform
so buckle up and let's get started with
mailchimp
so the first thing you need to do is
sign up for an account
with mailchimp and that simply just
providing an email address an id and a
password
and i recommend when you actually sign
up for an account
you sign up with the free plan first and
let's take a look at
what the feature plan features are for
mailchimp
so i'm recommending the free plan but
when you actually sign up
you have the option to actually pay for
a plan
so you have the essential the standard
the premium or the free
and so i recommend you go with the free
version first
it's like buying a car you want to test
drive it out see if you like it see if
you like the features and benefits
and you can see here that with the free
plan you get a lot of features and
benefits so you get all the basics
for businesses that are just getting
started so if you're just getting
started with email marketing
i would recommend the free plan here
because you have a 2000
contact maximum so that means you can
send out an email to
your 2 000 recipients free of charge so
not a bad deal for
businesses who are starting out i mean
if you are prepared you've used
mailchimp before
then go ahead and sign up for one of the
paid versions
each version has a different set of
standards
a different set of features and benefits
from the essential all the way up to the
premium where you're gonna get
you know advanced features um and more
customization but that's 299 dollars a
month so if you're not
prepared to pay that amount then my
recommendation start with that free plan
now when you actually do
set up your account you're just gonna
again provide a
id email address and password you're
gonna go through a couple of steps and
one of these steps that i would
recommend you do right away
is connect your facebook and twitter
accounts so if you already have a
facebook and twitter account very simple
all you're doing is authorizing
mailchimp to connect to the account
and the reason for that is when you
actually connect your twitter facebook
account
you'll be able to then you know share
content on those platforms
and mailchimp will do that for you
automatically okay so
here you're just asking it to more or
less interact with the platform social
platform and i recommend
doing that as you're going through the
setup process very simple to do
if you're already logged into your
twitter facebook account
all you need to do is click on the plus
button as you go through the
setup wizard and authorize mailchimp to
access your twitter or facebook account
here you can see
what mailchimp's going to be able to do
they're going to be able to retweets
from your timeline
post tweets for you on your behalf if
you want them to
if you want them to you're going to
allow mailchimp to secrete and manage
your advertising data including the
campaigns and audiences
and the reason for this is you may
you know want to integrate your email
marketing efforts
with your social media efforts and the
great thing about mailchimp
is hey look if you want to post content
on these platforms you'll be able to
if you want to leverage other benefits
from facebook and twitter and integrate
them
with mailchimp you'll be able to so
having these two platforms in the case
of facebook and twitter talk to
mailchimp
is a positive because then you'll be
able to do a little bit more
get your message out there a little bit
more so i highly recommend you take
this as a necessary step when you're
going through the setup now it's
optional you don't have to but i
recommend it
now when you're actually setting up your
account you're going to be asked to
you know design a template okay so you
could pick a template
just by default you could pick one just
to get the account going but you can
always go back
and add or change out the template so
here you can see i'm in the setup wizard
but i
arbitrarily just chose a template i can
go back and choose some of the templates
that are available to me
now again you can create your own
template if you want to okay
so you just click create template and
you'll be you know asked to choose kind
of a
you know template that you can pretty
much change
and customize so if you're thinking
about sending out an email
with an announcement then that's the
type of template you want to
choose and so here now you can see we
have a logo
we can change the announcement here we
can add photos
etc so if i want to add my logo i'm just
going to go up to this top portion here
click the little pencil icon that allows
me to edit
here you can see it's default logo i
don't really have a logo so i can say
replace it
i can also link to it and here you can
see
in the content studio of mailchimp i
don't have any images to choose from so
i'm going to go ahead and upload one
and i'm going to go ahead and upload my
logo that i've had on my desktop
okay so it's going to upload and now i
can select
that and insert it so now i have my logo
as part of my template here
and you can also see you can add some
styling here
to this header part so i can add a nice
border around that
okay so i can align its center i can go
edge to edge
okay so i can customize the image
in this particular template here so i'm
just going to click save and close
now i'm ready to move on to the next
part which is just click on edit
i want to make an announcement okay
share your big news
okay we're having a launch party okay so
here you can see again just in this
template this
quote unquote announcement template i'm
able to
just make changes to each section now
i'm in the section of the announcement
part
where i can now customize the text
and you can see i can you know bold it
you know i can choose a different font
go ariel i can choose the size you can
make it smaller
larger pretty easy to use i could again
style it with a different color
and so i can make multiple columns here
if i want to
so there's a lot you can do just in this
one section as well
so let's go ahead and just do one more
thing here
let's maybe covet or something i mean
you can see i can add a link
let's go ahead and make it blue that's
the background so i want to change the
background
so i'm just going to click control z
i'll change the color
of the font itself there you go very
simple
and easy to use now i can add photos
here
if i want to so let's go ahead and edit
this bottom part here so i'm going to
click again the edit icon okay so
here you can see i have three images in
the template i'm gonna go ahead and add
to that
so here i can go ahead and upload some
files
so i have some files waiting for me on
my desktop i'm just gonna go ahead and
add them
and upload them to the content studio
and
now that i've uploaded them i can select
one of them
to insert okay now i'm going to go here
insert the second one
and now i'm going to grab the third one
and insert that
in its place here you can see now i can
go ahead and
you know style each one of these if i
want to okay i can add a border again
okay i can go ahead and do rounded
corners okay
settings you can see how i can set it up
this so they're all vertical
i can do this so i have a lot of
flexibility
in what i add to these particular
you know templates okay this is again
just the announcement template
and so now i'm going to click save and
close and
here you can see i can add some other
things to it if i wanted to i can play
around with the design and header
and once i'm done really if i'm happy
with my email i can just close it out
and i'm done so what i could do now is
when you're done with this template
you can just preview and test it so i
could send a test email or
enter preview mode so if i enter preview
mode this is what the template i chose
is going to look like
if i happen to send it out okay this is
what it looks like on desktop
this is what it looks like a mobile and
if i go inbox preview
i'll need to upgrade my account because
i'm on the free version
so but i can certainly see what it looks
like on mobile on desktop so
i'm just going to click out of that and
this is a template
and so i can go back and edit this
anytime i want
so when i'm done i'm just going to go
ahead and click the mailchimp
icon in the upper left it's going to ask
me to
name my template so i'm going to name
this the announcement template
i'm going to click save and now it's in
my templates
so i'm free to use this template
anytime i'm ready to send an email okay
and again i can
you saw how easy it was to make a change
in the template itself so when i'm ready
to use the template i can just go ahead
and grab it okay and again
i can go ahead and style it and design
it any way i want
so you have different sections of the
page that you can style
and here you got you know mobile style
designs if you wanted to
now if you wanted to in the template if
i want to like duplicate the whole blog
i can duplicate that whole block and you
can see it just copied it or i can just
get rid of it
it's a very easy to use wysiwyg if you
will or interface
it allows you mailchimp allows from some
easy
you know functionality easy features to
go ahead and manipulate and change to
your liking okay so again
i'm working with a template here so
anytime i'm ready to use that template
for an email i can go in and start using
it
okay and if i go to templates again i'm
gonna find my template here i can always
edit it
i can always share it i can always
preview it i can replicate
it and that's the important thing so if
i replicate it i'm basically
creating a copy of it okay so i just
created a copy
so now if i wanted to create a or change
the copy of it i can do that
so if i don't like this whole block i
can just delete it
and now that i'm done i can rename this
i'm just going to say
announcement template v2 so now it's
been renamed
and now i have two templates just simply
by choosing one
and replicating it so again if i go back
to templates here
here i go i have my two templates and i
can store these in a folder so i'm going
to add a folder i'm going to call it
announcements
and i'm going to add the folder and
that's it so
now i can store these in the folder so
you can organize all your templates in
different folders if you want to so i'm
going to take these
two templates here move them to my
announcements folder
and there you go they're in the
announcements folder so if you're going
to create multiple templates then i
would recommend
you go ahead and organize it create
folders
you know and set up as many folders as
you want and need
because you're going to probably have
different templates for
different occasions depends on what type
of email you're sending out so i just
chose arbitrarily
an announcement type email so now if i
go back to create templates
okay you can see again let's go through
some of these others again i just chose
make an announcement you could tell a
story
follow-up educate you got all sorts of
different
templates that you could choose all
sorts and here you got some themes so
you can even go with a theme if you
wanted to
so for example if you're selling
products let's just say
you have a boutique store let's just
choose this boutique
template if i choose this here is my
themed template and so now just like the
other template i
was working in i can go ahead and edit
this here you can see at the top
i got the middle section you know i got
all these different
sections that i can now go ahead and
edit
so just about really it's about choosing
the theme
template that works best for you and
feel free to
you know try these different templates
out and see what works best
for you so here you can add in certain
things like
you know social share so if i just drag
and drop i can add in a social share or
image card
so a lot of these themes are very
flexible in what you can do
in terms of the design in terms of the
content so again if you go back
and i'm going to cancel and not save
this temp well let's save it we'll call
it boutique
we may use it again in the future so i'm
going to go ahead and click save
and now it's a template it's going to be
located in templates
and again if you always want to access
templates just go to templates you'll
see the templates that you already
have created and edited so you can edit
them always just by clicking the edit
button
now that's again if you want to create a
new template just create
click on the create new template call to
action again you got themes
you've got layouts or you can even
create your own from scratch
you can import another template that you
created in another
email marketing platform or you could do
simply just do everything from scratch
and html
so you have three different options here
layouts themes
and creating a template on your own okay
and that's either by
importing or by creating it from scratch
okay my recommendation
i like some of the layouts that
mailchimp has you can see a lot of
flexibility here and when you actually
choose one
again you're in full control of how to
design and message it so you're in full
control of that so if you just want it
again
tell a story i'm going to select this
template here okay
now i'm on the free version so keep in
mind
with the free version i don't have
access to all the templates so here i
got to upgrade to use this one but for
example
if i don't see the message upgrade to
use then i'm free to grab it so you can
see
the one column i'm free to use so i'm
just going to select that
and now i have this template available
to me so again i'm
free to edit this one as i see fit i
mean i can go ahead and
again drop in any one of these elements
that are available to me here
i'm going to drop in my social block
okay so here you can see i can now
customize my social block if i want to
add in another platform
i can do that social media platform
click save and close
so you can see they're very customizable
all of these themes and layouts are
very customizable and again when you're
done
it's just a matter of you can preview it
or test it you can enter preview mode or
you can send yourself a test email okay
if you send yourself a test email you
can actually see how it looks when it
comes in
so let's go ahead and do that here so
i'm just going to send myself a test
email
and the email has been sent so let's go
check our inbox
so here is the email that
i just created from the theme you can
see here all i did
simply when i edited i just dropped in
my social block in here so this is what
the email looks like and the great thing
about mailchimp is they have an option
that
you can view the email in a browser if
you can't
or you know don't want to look at it in
your in this case i'm looking at gmail
so you can always or recipients can
always view the email in a browser
versus the email client that they're
using in specific
now when it comes to completing your
profile
on mailchimp you're going to need an
audience to send these emails to
and so when you click on audience here
if you don't have an audience already
imported
into mailchimp you're going to be asked
to import so you can see i already have
one contact that contacts me
because i added my email address on that
test email
so mailchimp smart enough to say okay we
don't have this email address and our
contact list
so we're going to add them so here we
can see we can manage
our audience so we can add subscribers
we can import contacts
we can have sign up forms and we can
manage our contacts
so if we import our contacts if i click
on import
here i'm going to be asked to import
either from a csv
or copy and paste or i can just go ahead
and integrate it
so if i choose for example any one of
these
then it's going to pull in the context i
have there and so
it's up to you how you import your
contacts
now the whole point of contacts is you
want to probably
or really not probably it's a best
practice to actually
create different lists so that you can
use different
audience lists with different emails and
so here you can see i have one email
address i can again
import contacts or i can add them
individually
so i can add subscribers here okay
that's another option that's the slower
option my recommendation be
import them but when you import make
sure you you're importing lists
that have some commonality so you can
manage those lists so
if you have one list that are say you
know clients who have never purchased
then you want to create a list for them
if you have clients who have purchased
separate those out okay so that's the
way i would go about it
now if you're trying to build a list
mailchimp has what they call signup
forms so you have different forms that
you can embed and or have as a pop-up
and when people add their email address
to that form then it's automatically
going to get added to your mailchimp
account so that's a great feature in
mailchimp
that allows you to you know build out
your audience just by using one of their
forms so again we have a subscriber
pop-up
you've probably seen some of these on
some of the websites you've gone to
so you can customize it and if you want
somebody to subscribe to your newsletter
for example
all they need to do is enter in their
email address and click subscribe okay
that's the
the pop-up version now again you have
the opportunity to
you know use other forms as well so you
got a form builder
here or an embedded form okay or you can
integrate the form
okay so if i click form integrations
here i can use
wufoo or squarespace i can integrate
with them
if i go back to signup forms if i choose
form builder here i have a signup form
and then i can customize that form with
different boxes
okay or fields okay so whatever field i
want somebody to
add information to i can have that in
there and then
this form could be you know on your
website so that's the great
feature about mailchimp is it helps you
build an audience so i can add this form
to my website and anybody who fills out
that form is
going to be added to my subscriber list
that i can use for future emails to take
that a step further
i can even go from building a form to
building a landing page
so here you can see if i click on
audience i can go ahead
at the bottom right here i have an
option to create a landing page so if i
click on that
just like everything else in mailchimp
it's fairly easy to use i'm just going
to name it
test click begin here i can choose my
audience
again i can what audience do i want
to add these emails to i click begin
and i'm going to accept and here now i
have all these different templates that
i can use as a landing page
so if you want to use these landing
pages to collect
emails and those emails are gonna be
added to your audience then you have a
nice selection here
at your disposal okay so here i'm just
gonna choose one
you know grow my list okay this is a
landing page
so i can customize it just like i do
with my email template i can add my logo
okay i can start
adding different fields here like an
image i can drop an image here
okay i can go ahead and you know drop in
my social shares
okay i can drop in a box text box okay
and then i can start customizing it with
some text some imagery you know some
other information
again this is a landing page that i can
then add to my website
and so anytime somebody goes to the
landing page and fills out their email
address and hit subscribe
it's going to be added to that audience
list
and then i can turn around and send an
email using one of mailchimp's templates
to that audience
so mailchimp really does a great job of
allowing you to grow your list within
your own website via a landing page
a form submission or or forum or pop-up
so there are lots of different options
available to us
so i'm going to click save and close
here and now this landing page is
available to me
so i can customize the url i can edit
the audience that these
emails go to i can add a page title
and again i can edit the design so i can
really make this
an integrated part of my website by
designing it so it fits the feel and
look
of my website i can add a specific url
and i can add a nice page title to it so
mailchimp again does a great job
of just making it so easy for you to
build out a landing page
for you to use on your website to
collect email addresses
so if you're doing a pay-per-click
campaign on facebook or google
you can actually drive traffic to these
landing pages and get people to
fill out a form submission and when they
fill out the form submission that email
address is going to get added to your
audience that's an option or you can
just add it as part of your website and
people who go
there from say organic search can find
that page
and add their email address organically
so that's a great thing about the
audience feature
in mailchimp in that not only can you
select an
email template but you have options to
grow your audience okay
again importing contacts you can simply
just add contacts
you can add you know a form submission
via pop-up or regular form fields
to your website or you can add a landing
page so it's important to note that in
mailchimp
if you go to the content studio that's
where you're going to find all the files
that you've added to all your templates
or landing pages that you used before
so if i click on content studio here
here you can see the files i've added to
my templates
if you have products you can add your
products here okay so if you have an
e-commerce store
you could certainly add your products
and then those products can be used
on your landing page or your email
templates you have something called a
giphy
you can insert these into any of your
emails make it fun
exciting engaging here you have
instagram so
what you could do is you can integrate
you know any one of your instagram
accounts
if you have multiple accounts or via one
instagram account you can integrate that
one instagram account
in with your mailchimp account and when
you do that it's going to pull in
all the images that you've had on
instagram and then you have an
opportunity here just to add a logo okay
so you can use any of your instagram
images
within your emails use one of these cool
giffies
again you can import your products that
you can use for your email templates
or just keep tabs on all the files that
you've added before
just by clicking on my files now when
you get to the point
of building different audience lists
and sending down emails you're going to
have the option to
look at reporting to see how those
emails perform
for those specific audiences now again
an audience is
a set it's like a segment you know these
are set of individuals who are going to
receive a specific email
so in this example you can see i have
different audiences
and if we look at say any one of these
audience or even just go to all
audiences
we'll be able to see how we fared on
some of our emails
okay so for example if i send out an
email here
in april and this is april of 2019
i could see how many total subscribers
i've had
now along with the number of subscribers
you have
you have what we call open rate and
click-through rate
now we explain a lot of the reporting
and the specific email metrics and
another recording
that we did last week so if you're
interested in learning more about some
of the metrics then check out the video
that we have on youtube email marketing
tutorial uh we recorded this last week
go into details about all the different
metrics
you uh can learn about with email
marketing
so take a look at this video email
marketing tutorial it'll be a nice
precursor to the mailchimp tutorial so
to give you some insights
as to what metrics to really pay
attention to with email marketing but in
mailchimp
we know we can look at the total number
of subscribers
we know that we have how many opens and
we know what the open rate is and again
the total number of clicks
and what the click-through rate is okay
so with mailchimp very easily you just
hover over it
you get the raw number and then the
percentage so open rate is how many
people actually
open that email based on the total
number of people
that the email was sent to so here we
could see
in this particular email last year in
april
you know we've had fourteen percent
fourteen one point one percent to be
exact
and that is thirteen thousand three
hundred seventy seven divided by
ninety seven thousand four sixty nine so
that's how many people
open the email so thirteen thousand out
of ninety 97 is about 14
now when somebody opens it we hope
they're going to click on it and so here
we got a
1.4 percent click-through rate again
that's the
total number of clicks based on the
total number of subscribers or people
that were sent the email
and so mailchimp just gives you a nice
overview
of how many subscribers were in this
particular
audience list and then the open rating
click rate so we can
really dive in here and we can actually
see
how that particular email performs so if
we just pick one
email here we can just click view report
we have other options here
we can print we can download we can
share it
the whole campaign or just view the
email if we want to view what the email
look like we can select that so we just
want to view the report
so we're going to click view report and
now we can get into
some nice detailed information about the
actual
report itself so again here you can see
total number of recipients
and this came from the audience list
called newsletter
okay was delivered last year september
26 2018
again i have the option to view it
download it
print it or share it so let's take a
look and view the email to see what it
looked like okay so this is what the
email look like we have our own template
here
and here you can see it takes into
account some of the best practices
involved with email marketing you know
we have some nice content
imagery some call to action here some
other links
okay we have our social icons okay so
that's what the email looked like
okay so we'll go back and we're going to
click view report
now we want to view the report again
here's what it look
here's when it was sent okay the open
rate for this was 21 percent
click-through rate was four percent so
for us
the list average this list here
newsletter
the average was for the open rate 16.8
percent
so we're above the average on this email
for the click-through rate the list
average is 2.7
so we're above the average so we've done
a good job on this email at least
generating more opens more clicks and
mailchimp even takes that a step further
they'll even show you
what the industry average is for your
particular industry and in this case
we're education and training so we did
better
than the industry average for both the
open rate and for the click-through rate
so we could see some other specifics we
could see the raw numbers of opens
clicks how many people bounced meaning
the email address wasn't valid anymore
and so mailchimp does a good job of any
email that actually bounces
it'll be scrubbed and removed from your
list and then here you can see 347
unsubscribe
so the the thing about you know
mailchimp is we want to be careful we
don't have too many unsubscribes
and also people abusing or reporting
abuse
meaning you don't want to send out an
email multiple multiple times a week
where it gets the point where it's
spammy and so you want to avoid
a high number of unsubscribes and a high
number of abuse reports
and so here you can see most emails are
open within a 24-hour period
and then it kind of just tails off so
here we can see opens and clicks based
on
the time of day so within a 24-hour
period okay so this is how most emails
operate
within that first 24 hours you're going
to get a lot of opens a lot of clicks
and then it's going to tail off from
there great thing is mailchimp provides
me more detailed information about what
was clicked
so i could see here the top links that
were clicked
and let me just point one thing out here
whether you use mailchimp
or you use any other platform whether
that be vertical response
or any other type of email marketing
platform
you want to use utm tracking with your
links
so that google analytics can pick up
the actual campaign so here you can see
we have utm tracking
appended to our links and let me just go
in to detail on that for just a minute
so mailchimp again gives us nice
data on open and click-through rates but
when we send out an email and people
actually do
click on one of these links they're
going to go to our website and from
there
google analytics is going to take over
on the tracking so this is as far as
mailchimp goes so we want to be able to
bridge the gap between mailchimp
reporting
and google analytics meaning when they
came from the
email when and went to the site did they
convert meaning did they download
something did they purchase something
and so we want to be able to bridge the
gap and utm tracking
which is simply appending the original
url
with some tracking parameters named utm
it allows us to bridge that gap so all
you need to do
when you set up a mailchimp campaign is
just go to url builder
in google then you're going to click on
campaign
url builder and we're going to go ahead
and
set up an email campaign so for example
if we go back here
this was the original url so if i just
copy this original url here
and paste that as part of my website url
what's my campaign source i'm going to
put mailchimp what's my medium i'm going
to put
email so mailchimp is the source of
where the
traffic came from the medium the means
in which they
arrived at our website was via email and
the campaign name we're just gonna put
maybe whatever it is
summer promo so with the url builder you
have five
parameters for utm tracking you don't
have to use all five okay
so here we need to put in the url and we
need to put in the source
but the other four parameters medium
name
term and content are optional so you
don't have to put anything there but
the more parameters you put in the more
specific it is for you to track the
behavior of that email campaign
so here i can see mailchimp email summer
promo
and then for the content i can use that
to differentiate
my subject line so when you send out an
email we mention this in the email
marketing tutorial
you always want to send out multiple
subject lines meaning
one list gets one subject line another
list gets this
a second subject line because you want
to be able to measure
open rates based on subject lines so i
can use the campaign content parameter
for different subject lines and notice
the url builder once i enter in my
parameters
it's going to append the original url
with
a new url appended with utm tracking so
if i copy that
i can simply just paste that in my
browser just to see if it works
and here you can see it works the page
loaded
the original url with utm tracking and
so that's exactly what you want to do
because when you're looking at your
reports in mailchimp
it's going to show me the top links that
were clicked now if i go into analytics
i want to be able to see how that
campaign or how that link actually
performed so let's take a look at that
real quick
so if i go to my google analytics
account and i go to acquisition
campaigns all campaigns what am i
looking for well
if i click on source and medium source
and medium are two of the parameters
for utm tracking i'm going to look for
mailchimp so here i can see
um original url mailchimp and then the
date stamp
and then the mediums email so if i go
back here i can see for example
any one of these mailchimp emails that
went out and then i can see
how many people actually came from the
email what the balance rate was meaning
if they arrived on the site did they
leave
after arriving or they actually go to
another page
and then i could see other engagement
data like how many pages they looked at
did they how much time do they spend
more importantly did they convert so
that's the whole idea behind
using utm tracking because with utm
tracking
you can can bridge the gap from open
rate
click through rate to behavior on the
website all the way through to the
conversion and that's what we want to
measure we want to measure
did somebody go from the email open it
click on one of the links go to the
website engage on the website and
convert
and so that's the whole idea behind utm
tracking
because mailchimp and any other email
marketing platform
is only going to give you at most your
open rates and your click-through rates
okay so here we could see
the top links clicked i see 4 000
recipients clicked on this email they
went to the site
and now i need analytics to kind of tell
me the rest and here i can see what
subscribers
have the most opens and if i integrated
social i can see
some social performance and so that goes
back to our original setup so if you
integrate your twitter account or your
facebook account
you'll be able to integrate that email
in with your twitter
and then from there i'll be able to see
you know tweets
or or how many likes for example and to
top it off i can see
how many people from around the world
clicked on the email
so that's reporting in a nutshell on
mailchimp
reports are fairly easy to look at you
know all sorts of other information
like links specifically links uh you can
look at social
so if i click on the social tab here if
i integrated my social i can look at
social reporting
likewise for e-commerce and notice
analytics 360
i can integrate google analytics in with
mailchimp if i want to
so i have all sorts of options on my
reporting
so that's it for mailchimp i mean it's
fairly easy to navigate
you have all the campaigns that you've
sent out so if you just click on
campaigns
i'll be able to see all the campaigns
i've set up and all the campaigns that
have been sent
and obviously the ones that have been
sent i can start looking at reports
i can pick and choose templates okay i
can
pick and choose my audience and manage
my audience okay
i can see what the growth is from
audience again i have different
options to grow my audience okay i can
certainly add form submissions
landing pages sign up forms i can
import more contacts and i can manage
them through different lists
content studio is where all your files
are going to be located
from the files you've uploaded to
e-commerce
products to githi's to instagram
to my logo and then you have reports and
the reports are there
for you to measure the performance of
your email campaigns once they've been
sent so you can look at them from
reports
or just from the main campaigns view
that's pretty much it
so if you're ready to go at it again
click that create button
click that template choose that audience
you can go ahead and send yourself that
test email when you're ready
go ahead and send that email off to your
audience it's that simple in mailchimp
today we're going
to cover email marketing interview
questions
and answers so thanks for joining again
and here's how it's going to work
so if you have any questions to these
questions or answers feel free
to just comment right below this video
and we'll
get back to you as soon as possible
we're going to go through a series of
questions and i'm going to answer those
questions for you
so email marketing's traditional digital
marketing channel it's been around a
while
and you're going to be asked some
questions that are going to encompass a
lot of things
related to the delivery of emails
we all check emails on a daily basis we
all receive them
sometimes we receive emails unsolicited
sometimes we sign up to receive emails
sometimes we receive emails from
friends sometimes we receive emails
where
we're working or previously worked so
most people have an understanding of
email however
as a marketer there's a little bit of a
different twist
to it so we have to understand the
intricacies of how
email marketing works so you're gonna be
asked some questions
and really the first question here is
what's the difference between a hard
and a soft balanced email so if you're a
digital marketer you're in charge of
sending out lots of emails let's just
say
thousands or i mean it could be in the
hundreds of thousands of emails
you're going to get some bounces and so
you really want to know the difference
between a hard and a soft bounce so a
soft bounce just means that the email
message
reached the recipient's mail server
but bounce back is undelivered so think
of it as
delivering an actual mail to a post
office so it actually reached the post
office
but it bounced back because maybe
the you know person's email box was full
maybe their account was temporarily
disabled or maybe the email server
wasn't necessarily able to handle
that email now hard balance is an email
that
that is rejected because it's an email
when it
happens when the email has been
permanently rejected so for example
maybe the the the account is no longer
valid
and so let's look at some reasons again
as to
why a soft bounce would happen so for
example the inbox is full
or the recipient servers down so reach
the post office
but there was a problem actually getting
it into the hands of
the owner so to speak where the hard
balance a little bit different
let's just say that person is no longer
working their email has been deleted
or you the email has been blacklisted
somehow
okay a spam or something to that effect
so the email server is going to identify
that and it's not even going to reach
the recipient
so a lot of different ways in which an
email
may not make its recipient so now the
most important
thing to know here i just the important
thing to know is
listen when you send out an email you
got to pay attention to how many
get bounced back and so next question
here what would you do to improve the
click-through rate of
your email so click-through rate is
simply how many people have seen your
email
and how many people actually clicked on
a link in the email
so if hundred people saw your email but
only one person clicked then it would be
a one percent click-through rate
so we want to be able to make sure we
have a high click-through rate
so remember emails are going to people
who likely signed
up to receive your email and even if
they are expecting an email or they're
not expecting an email you still want to
follow some of these best practices here
one is to create a compelling subject
line so you want to make the subject
line
something that people are going to
notice take note of
or take an interest in and say hey
what's this all about that's pretty
interesting
and open the email so use preview text
effectively
obviously you want to make your email
mobile friendly because most people look
at their emails on their mobile
phones you want to create engaging
content okay so
the content that's in the email
obviously is going to have some links
so put some strong call to action in
there and that's one of the bullet
points down below place a cta
where it's easily visible so keep in
mind mobile users
most people are going to check that
email on their phone so you want to make
sure you have compelling content with
good
ctas in a visible location so always
check mobile as well as desktop
obviously in your emails you want to
make them
as visual as possible don't make them so
text heavy
you can always segment your emails
meaning if you're sending out an email
let's just say to a hundred people okay
maybe you want to divide it up boys or
girls maybe
older or young maybe you know living in
one part of the country versus another
part of the country i mean those are
examples of segments so
break up the email don't send it to
one mass email to everyone that way you
can personalize the email if an email is
personalized the chances of somebody
clicking on it are going to be greater
and then a b test your emails and when
we say a b test
you know you can send out the same email
twice
except one segment is going to say get
one version of the email the other
segment is going to get another version
of the email and what are the different
versions
maybe the subject line so the subject
line is different on
version a versus version b or maybe the
call to action is different so you
always want to
send out different versions of the same
email to a different segmented audience
that way you can actually see
which segment or which version got the
most clicks
okay so next question here is how to
inform your customers about company news
and establish a relationship
with your target audience okay so again
how do you inform your customers about
what's going on in the company
and how are you going to establish a
relationship with that audience who's
receiving that email
well newsletters are always the best
answer here
so somebody signs up for your email
let's just say they actually
purchase a product from you newsletters
are great way to reach out to that
audience to get them to
stay up to date with the latest product
or an improved version of the product
they purchased
and then that way they can come back and
continue to purchase the product
so newsletters are great way to reach
out to
your audience and actually talk to your
audience and you're not talking
verbally you're talking to them via
email so you send out that email
campaign maybe it's once a month hey
we noticed you bought this product we
have similar products
just like the one you bought or hey you
know if it's a software
maybe hey we've got upcoming updates to
our software make sure you go to the
website and get the updates
or we have a new and improved version so
all these things you want to communicate
to your audience via email
that's going to get them to get to the
website and that's going to get them to
you know purchase more update upgrade
whatever
so newsletters the way to go so again
some basic tips here
you want to create your newsletter with
90 educational and 10 percent
promotional so remember you're sending
out a newsletter to people who
likely signed up so you're educating
them about
your products always create interesting
subject lines you want
whether they know you or not you want to
create the subject line so somebody's
going to click on it
so make sure you design your emails
appropriately okay so
if you know you're sending let's just
say baby products
to mothers or expected mothers in fact
this is a real life example because i
used to work at
a gap and baby gap was
you know one of the emails groups i was
responsible for so we created an email
template with
softer colors your yellows your your
light blues
you know it wasn't black or dark red or
anything that's going to be
you know heavy we knew who our audience
was and we designed the template
accordingly and of course
using compelling images so for selling
baby products
you're going to put baby product images
in there i mean it's common sense but
you'd be surprised
you gotta pick and choose your images
carefully especially if you're sending
to an international audience because
images can be misconstrued and just like
we mentioned with the click-through rate
you always want to
have a clear cta always make sure you
have a cta in a visible position
because most people are going to look at
that email in a mobile phone okay and
then always make sure you include your
contact information
in the newsletter so somebody knows
where to
find you how to contact you where to go
maybe they have a product they want to
return
okay so you always want to put that
contact information
normally it's at the bottom of the email
but these are all best practices so
here's some examples okay we got you
know check out the latest cosmetics from
our new collections
notice the image and notice the call to
action so you can see trendy collections
you know we got some other
products you may want to buy okay five
important skin care products that
everyone should have
view more so you always want to have
that call to action
in a very visible place so define
following metrics open rate
click-through rate and response rate and
forward rate
so these are metrics related to email
marketing
so you're gonna have to know what these
are so we already mentioned
click-through rate
before when we talked about best
practices for improving the
click-through rate so
for those of you that remember what that
is go ahead and put that
in the comment section below just a
little pop quiz for you
if anybody remembers click-through rate
but let's take a look at open rate so
open rate is the percentage of the total
number of recipients
who actually open the email so if you
send it to
x amount of people how many people
opened it that would be the open rate
so how many people open it but you're
gonna take out the people who balanced
it
whether it's a soft bounds a hard bounce
okay you're not gonna count those people
so if you have let's just say 20 people
open the email and you send it to a
hundred people
then and you had nobody balanced then it
would be a 20 open rate okay
click-through rate
again pop quiz it's just how many people
actually
clicked on any of the links in your
email
and that's just divided by the number of
emails you've sent out a response rate
okay so response rate is the percentage
of the total recipients
who clicked on the link of your email
campaign and
actually completed an action so what is
that action well it could be
downloading something watching something
purchasing something
so that's the response rate similar to
conversion rate if you're working in a
digital marketing channel and you're
driving traffic to the site you want
that traffic to do something well it's
no different in email marketing we want
people to take action
we're just going to divide that by the
number of emails delivered
and that gives you your response rate so
let's just say you did send in 100
emails
you did get 20 open it and of this 20
let's just say one person went on a
purchase
well you'd have a one percent response
rate and then a forward rate
simply the forward rate refers to the
rate at which your subscribers share
your email
uh with others friends family etc and
you may
have that as a call to action in your
email in fact that's a best practice
so it's just the number of clicks on a
share divided by the total number of
delivered emails
and you're going to multiply that by 100
to get the percentage and so
most email marketing platforms do
measure
forward rate okay let's take a look at
how to recapture
inactive customers what you want to do
here is re-engage
subscribers with gamification opt for
subject lines like we have been missing
you
or did we do something wrong you want to
run a poll
or a competition and re-engage their
subscribers again
trying to get people involved these
first three are all about getting people
involved so personalize your emails talk
to that person as if
hey look i haven't heard from you in a
while how about coming back and taking a
look at
our new products just as you would a
friend so
design always matters especially knowing
that you're talking to customers who
haven't been active okay this is a
segmented audience
somebody who's inactive so you want to
have the right design the right message
the right subject line that fits with
that
customer's inactivity so you're going to
try and do everything you can to get
that customer back
and then you want to follow a consistent
schedule
okay so ideally when you schedule an
email you want to schedule the best
time so you have to know your audience
obviously and then
you can always ask for feedback why are
they inactive why haven't they purchased
in a while
so the whole idea here from gamification
like trying to you know make a game out
of it
so make it competitive to adding polls
to really personalizing it these are all
things that you can do to get your
customers back so what are the different
ways to segment buyer personas so
again when we talk about segmentation
we're talking about taking a smaller
piece the entire pie so
what's one way to break up that pie if
you will by geography
okay so with geography you could target
your audience based on
that area and it could not necessarily
have to be by
a part of the country it could be all
the way down to
the province the state the actual city
the county
okay if you live in a small village okay
all the way up to the continent
okay so think about how you would break
out the segment by geography
now obviously if you break it out let's
just say the united states
to the southern part well the southern
part you know in the winter
in the united states the southern part
is not going to be as cold to say the
northern part so
that should tell you hey if we're going
to send out an email in the winter
we're not going to use snow and and
blizzards as our theme
we're going to use probably a little bit
of sun so breaking it out by geography
helps you understand where your audience
lives you also have demographic
segmentation and this is simply just
age education income gender you know
where people work okay nationality
anything that's going to identify that
user
so this is the best way to segment if
you know who your audience is
by income or gender i mean you're
talking to a group
of like-minded people if they're all the
same age from the same generation then
you could talk to them appropriately
and you're not going to talk to an older
person the same way you would a younger
person so
think about demographic segmentation
because it really helps you
hone in on your messaging then you have
behavioral segmentation so behavioral is
based on
your audience's behavior have they
purchased before have they never
purchased were they searching for
something
how long did they stay on the site what
products were they looking at
are they a lifetime customer so you can
look at behavior
and decide how you want to break out
your emails by behavior and this is a
really good way if you're not even sure
who your audience is or where they live
and how old they are
you could certainly break out your
audience by behavior
because you know who these people are
based on what they've done previously
because you're going to track that
information with analytics so you know
one way
is obviously if somebody's purchased
that's a good way to segment because you
know these people
believe in you believe in your business
believe in your product so
the way you can message to somebody
who's purchased before is going to be
different than
somebody you don't even know who they
are if they purchased or not
okay so behavioral segmentation to me is
one of the easiest things
the easiest ways to segment your email
list how would you drive
repeat customers through email marketing
for the below scenario okay so this is a
pop quiz if you will again
for those of you that got click-through
rate correctly kudos let's see if you
can go two for two here
okay so if you know the answer to this
go ahead and comment below
but let's just say give a few examples
of subject lines to drive engagement for
audiences based on the following
if i had an audience between 20 and 30
years old
that were female and the product were
sandals okay what would some of your
subject lines be
so i'm going to give you a minute to
think about that and put it
in the comments section below now
remember this is an interview
based question so you're gonna have to
think on the spot
i'm gonna give you a minute but if
somebody presented that to you in an
interview
you need to be able to you know react
fairly quickly
and come up with some really attractive
subject lines here
okay so here you go here's another one
uh
so give a few examples of subject lines
to drive engagement for
20 to 30 females for footwear so you got
friday sale coming up
buy branded sandals at the lowest price
okay so
i like this one because it's got a
strong call to action
buy here you go this is even better
because
50 off on branded sandals and free
shipping i mean who can't
beat free anything including shipping
and if it's 50
off i mean these are key things so
you're putting the promotion and
percentage off
all in the subject line so that's really
going to grab somebody's attention
weekend sale for women starts now okay
with a little emoji
that never hurts so those are all good
subject lines
they all tend to work because they all
have an element of a best practice in
there
so here you got you know the friday sale
coming up
is just giving people notice okay the
stronger call to action on the buy
you're putting the promotion in the
subject line
and you know using an emoji to really
just drive home the point
so all these subject lines will work and
hey at the end of the day
remember you want to test your subject
lines okay moving on to the next
question
speaking of testing what does a be
testing and give some examples of a b
testing
okay so we talked a little bit about a b
testing with subject lines
so simply a b testing when it comes to
email marketing it's just a method to
analyze
which of the two email campaign
strategies is most effective
all right you know you're gonna do it
based on open rate you can do it based
on click rate you can do it based on
response rate
and remember you're putting one version
of the email against another version
whether that be the subject line whether
it be the content
call to action whatever so that's
ideally what you're trying to do you're
trying to figure out
what works for your audience that's the
end goal
for email for a b testing and email
marketing what's going to work
and i would highly suggest you should
always do a b testing for subject lines
always so some of the variables that you
can test
again subject lines okay you always want
to try if you got a promotion hey will
the
percentage off work likely it will but
let's test it up against something else
like
you know a generic word like discounts
you can always
test the design you can always test the
personalization
the preview text you could try out
images call to actions
exclusive offers what particular offer
is going to work
okay so if you're testing offers then
obviously that's going to be response
rate if you're testing
ctas and that's going to be
click-through rate if you're testing
subject lines that's going to be open
rate so you want to be able to test
different elements of the email to
figure out what works and what doesn't
work okay
so how to prevent email from getting
into spam so if you're an email marketer
this is your worst nightmare
you don't want your emails to get
spammed so
that doesn't bode well for you so most
email marketing
platforms like mailchimp or constant
contact
measure spam so some of the important
ways to prevent this is
hey improve your open rate remember
going back to the first question
second question you want to have really
good subject lines here
okay and you want to segment your
audience so if you're if you know who
you're talking to and you have a cool
subject line that's going to get
somebody to react and open and that's
going to prevent somebody from spamming
your email
okay you can always customize your from
to make it look like it's coming from in
this case rob sanders
check if you have included an
unsubscribe link
okay so get people the option to
unsubscribe they don't have the option
unsubscribe
they could just report you as spam make
sure your emails work on different
devices
okay you want to optimize your images
for email make sure they're
not big and they don't fit on a mobile
device
okay prefer more text and fewer images
and then avoid grammatical issues you
want to come across as professional
you don't want somebody looking at your
email like who sent this
why you sending this to me i don't want
to hear from you again i'm going to spam
you
you want to prevent that and that means
a professional looking email
professional content with a really good
subject line and some imagery to go
along with that
hey you may just get somebody to open
that email and get them to convert
that's the idea behind it so these are
ways to prevent
somebody from actually spamming you and
then
what are the best practices for email
subject lines so the subject line is the
most
probably the most important element in
email marketing
so we talked about that little pop quiz
with the sandals
targeting 20 to 30 year old women you
know to me i like the subject line
with the 50 off so that was a number
in the subject line so people can
actually see hey
wow i get a whole 50 percent that works
better than just a discount okay
remember one of those subject lines had
an emoji so don't be afraid to include
emojis in there for example
when i send out emails using you know
during the spring
you might want to use flowers perhaps to
signify hey it's spring
winter's over so personalize the subject
lines
remember that goes with segmenting so if
you know who your audience is
your subject lines can be a little bit
more personal okay so off for
title case subject lines okay so instead
of
making it grammatical for example okay
you want to keep your
subject lines short and to the point
remember you want to say something
that's going to draw somebody's
attention
if you make it long and drawn out and
boring then
people aren't going to open it develop a
sense of urgency like hey
we got 50 off through friday so
that's a little sense of urgency so
people know hey if it's thursday
i better open this email and check it
out and again grammatical mistakes that
goes without saying
you always want to preview your emails
before you send them out
so if you preview your emails before you
send them out have somebody else
obviously receive the preview they can
be another set of eyes for you
to prevent any mistakes but also give
you feedback on the imagery the design
etc okay so these are all best practices
for good subject lines okay so subject
lines are most
important element for email marketing so
just keep
these in mind subject lines and having
good subject lines
is the way to get people to open it and
from there that's half the battle
somebody can open the email
then you've just set yourself up for
better performance and with that we have
come to the end of this video on
email marketing full course i hope it
was informative and interesting
if you have any questions about the
topics covered in this video
please ask away in the comment section
below our team will help you solve your
queries thanks for watching
stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here